i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
well unfortunately it's looking like the
fourth of july federal holiday here in
the united states is an increasingly
dangerous day
it's sort of beyond the scope of today's
show to give you the details of every
mass shooting and incident of gun
violence that took place over the fourth
of july weekend hint there were about 13
or 14 different mass shootings over the
weekend
but i want to talk about the reaction
the increasingly
i i mean it it's an absurd reaction that
exists in the united states to these
incidents again the focus from the
american right wing is on everything
other than the tools with which the
shootings themselves are carried out the
guns and it's now not only about doors
it's about ladders
it's about rooftops it's about alleys
unsecured alleys and i will explain it
all but in very rough strokes
another two
i mean listen there were multiple mass
shootings yesterday
the two that made the most headlines
include one in the swanky
chicago suburb of highland park which
took place during a fourth of july
parade where the shooter used a ladder
to get to a rooftop the shooter was
eventually captured by police and taken
into custody alive then there was
another incident where
as of this moment it appears that two
police officers at minimum were shot
during uh a fireworks event in
philadelphia pennsylvania and
immediately we see the focus go to
things that don't really make any sense
in highland park well uh well let's go
backwards in uvalde texas the problem
was there were too many doors at the
school the doors were the problem
and ted cruz and others saying
reduce the number of doors secure the
doors etc
in highland park illinois the shooter
used a ladder to get to a rooftop so the
problem is well we you can't just re
leave random ladders around where
anybody could get to a rooftop too many
rooftops in the city that's a problem
unsecured rooftops and i put out a few
tweets about this
which many of you which seemed to
resonate with many of you and they were
sort of tumbling tongue-in-cheek the
first one was
doors clearly are not a solution for
mass shootings like today's
so what is the next proposal from
republicans to avoid dealing with the
guns
and in the replies it's filled with
people saying well they're going to talk
about rooftops and ladders and all of
these things and they did
i then tweeted well ban rooftops
buildings should only have a bottom not
a top of course that's absurd
but these are the types of reactions
that we're seeing maybe ban parades
maybe we have to harden the parade
routes almost as if it's the you know
when there's a presidential inauguration
they harden
the route that the presidential
motorcade will take maybe every random
parade now needs that maybe ladders
should be registered no age limit to buy
a ladder but certainly we need a
national registry of everybody that bans
ladders
what of what i'm saying is a joke i
don't even know at this point i don't
even know because they want to deal with
everything
other than the firearms the uh police
commander
who is this this is the deputy chief
of lake county's sheriff department
christopher cavelli was asked
how did the shooter get to the roof
well it wasn't secured check this out
so the roof was a business and it looks
like uh access
uh to the roof via a ladder in an alley
was unsecure
right
over there
a ladder that's attached to the building
guys there's all these ladders sometimes
they're fire escape ladders
they're all over the place they're
completely unsecured obviously because
people need those if there's a fire
they've got to get out well do we ban
the ladders or do we register the fire
escapes or do we lock them well but then
how do people escape well but then
there's elevators do
maybe the elevators need to be banned or
secured or well oh no but if the
elevator then there's the internal
staircases in the building we've got to
harden all ladders elevators staircases
and rooftops
well maybe that's not the solution maybe
instead
we just need bulletproof vests at all
parades because listen
they're gonna get up onto the roof they
might have a gun or they might have a uh
they might have a machete which they
could throw
from the rooftop so you've gotta wear a
bulletproof vest when you go to a parade
that's the solution now
uh and unfortunately
some of them seem to now be accepting
that we're just gonna have these types
of events but it's okay because we're
gonna we need to have the guns j.r
majewski the trumpian u.s house
candidate who i interviewed
he posted yesterday i don't care if
countries in europe have less shoot by
the way it should be fewer shootings but
that i'm reading it as written i don't
care if countries in europe have less
shootings because they don't have guns i
care about the united states of america
and our second amendment rights i think
americans stopped caring what europe
thought of our country in 1776
he's straight up saying it is more
important
to have guns
than to not have mass shootings
ted cruz
immediately sending prayers ted and
heidi they sent prayers
and to that i asked on twitter
we've had another mass shooting
someone didn't pray hard enough
or correctly
or to the right deity who was it guys
prayer that's how we stop this i'm
looking at you which one of you didn't
pray correctly or to the right god or on
the right day or enough times per month
one of you is responsible because you
did faulty prayer
come on guys we how do we win this when
half the country well
maybe not half
when a significant portion of the
country
including many of the moneyed interests
that influence gun policy are just
accepting we will send prayers but we
won't do anything about guns
okay we'd rather not have mass shootings
but if we have to have them in order to
keep our guns it's acceptable how can we
possibly deal with this issue when
that's the case one guy who is basically
ready to throw in the towel personally
and i sympathize with him is the mayor
of philadelphia and i want to talk about
that next so the mayor of philadelphia
is jim kenney and he is being attacked
very significantly right now because he
said you know what i look forward to not
being mayor so i can stop worrying about
these constant mass shootings i told you
that it was a disastrous fourth of july
weekend in the united states something
like 13 14 15 mass shootings in the
united states over the fourth of july
weekend two
major major ones it's crazy to say in
the u.s we have
major mass shootings
and then we have minor mass shootings
which don't make national headlines
necessarily two of the major mass
shootings we had one was in the chicago
suburb of highland park
the other was in philadelphia during a
fireworks display for the fourth of july
and after the shooting in which two
police officers were shot during the
fireworks show and concert uh at the ben
franklin parkway in philadelphia the
mayor of philly jim kenny said
i'm up all night every time we have a
large event i'm staring at the ceiling
worried about a mass shooting i look
forward to no longer being the mayor
and this caught some people by surprise
oh is that appropriate the mayor doesn't
even want to be mayor that doesn't sound
good no it's not good and i completely
sympathize with jim kenny here's what he
had to say i am because i'm concerned
every single day there's not an event or
a day where i don't lay on my back and
look at the ceiling and wonder worry
about stuff so everything we have in the
city uh over the last seven years i
worry about i don't enjoy fourth of july
i don't enjoy the the democratic
national convention i'd enjoy the
the nfl draft i'm waiting for something
bad to happen all the time so it's i'll
be happy when i'm not here when i'm the
mayor and i can enjoy some stuff so
you're looking forward to not being
mayor yeah
you're looking forward to not being
mayor yeah and who could possibly
disagree with what he's saying the guns
are absolutely everywhere no matter what
he does in philly pennsylvania has rules
and the surrounding states have rules
and it's so easy to get almost whatever
you want
and so whenever there's a mass event
fourth of july whatever he's saying uh
is this going to be the one
where we are the target
and yesterday they had one of those
incidents so i don't really understand
the criticism he's not saying he doesn't
care about philadelphia he's not saying
he doesn't care about
the people of the city or whatever he's
saying the toll that it is taking that
whenever we do anything i'm up at night
staring at the ceiling wondering is this
the one where a shooter shows up is this
the one
and he can't take it and that makes
sense many of us can't take it it's
absolutely horrifying what's going on so
uh jim kenny's fine there's there's no
there's no big so oh god we've got to
remove him he says he doesn't want to be
mayor he's looking forward
to when it is not on him
that at anything he does in the city
there could be
another outcropping of this plague that
we have in the united states of mass
shootings and shooters uh so that's jim
kennedy and i i
ver very much identify with the way he's
feeling all right let's change gears a
little bit let me ask you a question do
any of you believe that joe biden is
running for re-election in 2024 i mean
do any of you think that he is i don't
and this is my opinion and i know that
it's considered sometimes inappropriate
to say well if he hasn't said he isn't
running david sir you shouldn't really
be saying it because you might
demoralize i give you my opinion on this
show my opinion is there is no sign
whatsoever that joe biden is running for
re-election in 2024. kamala harris
recently had to walk back a statement
she made kamala harris during an
interview said joe biden is running
and i will be his running mate
and the next day she had to back it up
and say well actually uh joe biden
intends to run and when you keep hearing
intends to run
and they go beyond it and say he's
running and then they've got to back it
up and say that what i meant was he
intends to run not that he is running
it points to me that there is no way joe
biden is running for re-election so
let's look at a couple of clips here's
the first one this was an interview that
vice president kamala harris gave to cnn
and she sounded very definitive early
last week take a look joe biden is
running for re-election and i will be
his ticket mate wow
full stop close stop right sounding
incredibly confident and yet
then she had to back it up
from the la times vice president harris
says biden intends to run for
re-election this was two days later vice
president kamala harris created new
uncertainty wednesday about president
biden's intentions to run in 2024
pulling back from the definitive
statement she made earlier in the week
the president intends to run
and if he does
i will be his ticketmate
we will run together we will run
together that is not the confident
statement that she made on monday
we have seen this language before you
might remember that many times when
former white house press secretary
jensachi was asked is joe biden running
for reelection because he hasn't
declared his candidacy she would go with
this phrase intends to run here's just
one example of that there was another
round of stories over the weekend about
the political fate of the president and
the vice president
and who might run in 2024
and it quotes a lot of
other democrats or people who work for
them
what is the white house's message to
those democrats
the white house's message is we're
focused right now on what the american
people elected the president to do less
about just over a year ago which is to
get covet under control to put people
back to work
and to help give people some breathing
room and we hope other people keep their
focus on that as well should they knock
it off
is that speculation the president has
every intention of running for
reelection so that's the other message
for them every intention there is an
intent to run for reelection guys i
don't think joe biden's running and we
very rarely on this program talk about
an election that's not the next one the
next one is in
uh four in four months
that's the one we would normally
exclusively be talking about we have a
very different situation right now where
i believe there is every sign that joe
biden is not going to run for
re-election he would be 82 at the time
of the next term and it's just not
seeming to me like he's going to run his
vice president kamala harris who would
often be the natural person to run if it
is not the president himself is
extraordinarily unpopular kamala harris
as of right now that could change but
right now she's very unpopular and there
are increased whisperings that donald
trump will soon be declaring his
candidacy for 2024.
my belief at this point is
joe biden if he is not going to run
should announce it sooner than later
probably not before the november
election it seems to me that it would be
more prudent to wait until the midterms
and then for joe biden to relatively
quickly say i am not going to run for
re-election why
if donald trump does declare or he
declares that he's not running and it's
there's a focus on desantis as they're
increasingly is or whatever
it seems like a bad
recipe
to have an aggressive republican
candidate who has announced they are
running
out there attacking biden
and biden not planning to run but not
saying he isn't planning to run and
democrats just will be weakened and
weakened and by the time democrats have
a nominee by the time joe biden says i'm
not running by the time it gets sorted
out whoever is the strongest de facto
candidate on the republican side has had
months if not years to prop themselves
up and to beat down on the democratic
party and whoever uh eventually intends
to run
so
unfortunately there's a bit of a
reactive element where
if trump says he's running or if trump
says he's not and there are rumors he
may do this soon
i believe that is bad for whoever is the
eventual nominee
be it joe biden or not and so if biden
is not running my belief is he should
make that known sooner than later
ideally not before the midterms let me
know your thoughts whether you agree or
disagree i want to hear from you you can
find me on twitter at dpakman and we'll
be back right after this
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds this has
happened to me before i've talked on the
show we got hacked it was costly it
wasn't a good feeling and that's why i
now protect myself with aura one of our
sponsors protecting your accounts and
devices gets complicated because you
need a bunch of different tools and aura
combines them all into one app identity
theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches probably
something you want to know and it's free
so you might as well just use the link
down below
the david pakman show is a community
supported program i invite you to sign
up on our website
joinpakman.com that's p-a-k-m-a-n
you can use the coupon code big voting
22 that's what we need in november to
get a discount off of the cost of a
membership you'll get the extra bonus
show every single weekday you'll get a
commercial free audio feed of the show a
commercial free video feed of the show
exclusive priority access to david
pakman show audience town halls and the
daily show you will get up to six hours
earlier then we make it public for
everybody a nice little set of benefits
i have to say and you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
we are going to now look
at a republican primary so absurd
so unhinged so disconnected and
untethered from reality
that someone who's really pretty nuts
politically liz cheney looks like the
voice of reason in comparison and i'm
going to explain that i'm going to
defend that statement liz cheney is a
current um house of representatives um a
congresswoman representing wyoming in
the u.s house of representatives she's
got quite a primary uh she has become a
popular target of donald trump's popular
target of the trumpian right and they
want to get her out and wyoming pbs held
the debate between liz cheney and her
challengers and liz cheney is a
republican whose politics i disagree
with who recently said insane things
about abortion but alongside the cast of
characters running against her
she seems completely sane and normal
check out this series of highlights this
looks like a saturday night live skit it
really does but these are the people
that she's running against and you'll
see that when we hear from liz chaney
kind of sprinkled in here she sounds
completely sane because of the people
around her check this out we're going to
go to what we call a lighting round
january 6th was a set up from the
beginning we cannot have uh actual um
oh gosh
see i'm
anyway what we saw happen on january 6
was
clearly an attempt to
delay the count of the electoral votes
coronavirus vaccine policy
they knew
fauci had awards
for his work in cytokines mr fauci is
one of the most corrupt
individuals in washington dc we are to
oppose any vaccines everybody ought to
get vaccinated and we need to do
everything we can to protect ourselves
from future viruses
right compared to the rest of them liz
cheney sounds sane residents faith in
the election process
i understand when i talked to mike
lindell he did say that there was a
small small portion
of uh voter fraud in this state but that
is alarming what about
uh
uh facebook
uh
using the the system to to to steer
people uh we we know for a fact all the
major
internets do that the two uh we have a
number of internets
and we're going to be looking at them
very very strongly thousand mules movie
is something that i think we have great
concern about voting machines that you
know are suspected fraud there are
politicians in this country beginning
with donald trump
who have lied to the american people he
consistently has said that the election
was stolen when it wasn't
ukraine
ukraine is corrupt
we started it we got involved we pushed
them into
being against
uh the russian government money
laundering i think that's the biggest uh
ticket for
the ukraine's and the biden
administration it's the front line in
the battle for freedom
and i think we've got to elect serious
leaders
yeah the ukraines i like that the only
serious person on the stage is liz
cheney and she's pretty nuts i disagree
with her politics but to some degree on
some issues she's tethered to reality um
she went on later in the debate to point
out that her opponent um hegemon i
forget her first name
um
the things that hageman is saying about
the election are the exact same claims
that got rudy giuliani and sidney powell
disbarred as attorneys
i think that that in wyoming we have
tremendously secure elections
i also know that the truth matters
and the claims that mrs hageman is
making about the 2020 election are the
same claims for which the president's
lead lawyer rudy giuliani was disbarred
true they are the same claims for which
sydney powell has had her law license
suspended right they are simply not true
it is not true that there was sufficient
fraud to change the results of the 2020
election the president's own attorney
general has said that the president's
own deputy attorney general has said
that and i mean president trump
president trump's uh campaign manager
said that president trump's white house
counsel said that president trump's own
family all right so you get it she
sounds completely sane and yet
just 12 hours ago liz cheney made some
wild claims
about democrats murdering babies she's
nuts
but she's a lot less nuts than the
people on the stage with her it is a it
is it it's a circling the drain of sorts
that we have it's a race to the bottom
uh and that's to make sure that every
american understands what today's
democrat party stands for with respect
to babies and with respect to the murder
of babies
we have seen now in states across the
country the introduction of legislation
that would enable the killing of babies
this is not about abortion this is about
killing babies after they are born she
is also bonkers
but look at the people running against
her this does not bode well for the
country
that debate looked almost like it would
be a skit i don't i don't actually know
like that lightning round thing is so
cartoonish
if saturday night live wants to do a
parody of it if they want to satirize it
how do they do it i'm not even sure they
can because it's a parody of itself
and uh who
whoever wins in that race it's bad
liz cheney i guess is sort of like
marginally less bad and that's uh about
that that's the most positive spin i can
possibly put on it the former president
donald trump
is freaking out over possible criminal
charges coming his way and speaking of
liz cheney he's calling out liz cheney
as being despicable trump completely
lost it on his uh social media platform
i guess we call it truth social truth
essential yeah uh trump freaks out over
possible criminal charges by blasting
war-mongering and despicable human being
liz cheney
i still do not believe that donald trump
is going to be charged it's just an
opinion and it's an empirical question
at some point he will either be charged
or he won't
and i don't know eventually he'll die
and at that point we would say well he's
not going to be charged
it's over he's not going to be charged
we will know the answer at some point
in the interim my opinion is trump is
not going to be charged at least not
likely for anything related to the
january 6 committee although if charges
are coming i think they're more likely
to come from georgia and his attempts
there to a strong arm his way into
getting georgia's electoral votes i need
11 000 votes give me a break so donald
trump over the fourth of july weekend
took to his truth social platform
with a completely unhinged message
saying quote and i will try to do this
in the best most accurate way possible
quote
warmongering and despicable human being
liz cheney who is hated by the great
people of wyoming down 35 keeps saying
over and over again that her fake
unselect committee may recommend
criminal charges against the president
of the united states who got more votes
than any sitting president in history
although millions of votes fewer
than joe biden he doesn't mention that
even the dems didn't know what she was
talking about why doesn't she press
charges instead against those that
cheated on the election there's no
evidence anyone did or those that didn't
properly protect the capital he went on
to say why doesn't the highly partisan
unselect committee of political capital
t thugs the same people all trump haters
and profiteers books speeches etc that
were involved with impeachment hoax
number one impeachment hoax number two
the no collusion mueller report and
overall the all caps now greatest witch
hunt in the history of the usa go after
the people who have been rioting
burning down cities
what city burned down
leading the massive crime wave
and killing many all over the us
including drug and human traffickers
no
let's get trump then he went donald
trump yeah donald trump
trump's worried trump's unhinged trump's
out of control
that being said
i really don't think he has much to
worry about in terms of criminal charges
now he also completely misunderstands
how the january 6 committee works he
talks about well why don't they go and
press charges against someone else the
january 6 committee doesn't press any
charges the january 6 committee
investigates with the investigative
power that house committees have
if
in their investigation they uncover
potential or evident
uh evidence of criminality they can make
a referral to the justice department to
attorney general merrick garland and
they may do so now to trump's benefit if
you have to say well why is it looking
not so bad for trump
there is no evidence whatsoever that
attorney general merrick garland has any
interest in indicting a former president
there's just no reason to think that he
is willing to do that the january six
committee has exposed so much and the
justice department has said well we're
paying attention to the proceedings oh
okay well what do you plan to do
are you even willing
to do what the evidence suggests you
should do
if indeed that is what surfaces well
they're not commenting on that much like
i said earlier in the show i'm seeing no
evidence that joe biden is actually
going to run for reelection i'm seeing
no evidence that the merrick garland
justice department is truly willing
to prosecute a former sitting president
and so we may see something out of
georgia the fact that trump is going so
nuts should be interpreted not as a sign
that he's likely to be indicted but is a
sign that he has done things worthy of
an indictment that's the guilty
conscience that i see from trump but i
don't actually think he has anything to
worry about let me know what you think
we'll have all the clips
and trump's truth social truth central
posts on the david pakman show instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
a 10 year old girl
is now being denied an abortion in ohio
and is going to have to travel across
state lines in order to get an abortion
because of a pregnancy that resulted
from a rape now a few people emailed me
last week saying you know david you
played this clip of the speaker of the
house of mississippi saying i would be
against an abortion even for a 12 year
old made pregnant by her own father and
some of you wrote to me and said that
was such a meaningless clip david
because it's a hypothetical that's just
that guy's opinion there is no such
situation and his opinion isn't the law
in mississippi anyway so it doesn't
matter well these are relevant
hypotheticals because they do happen and
here is a non-hypothetical a non-hype
this is a real story
the hill reports ten-year-old girl
denied abortion in ohio
a ten-year-old girl was denied an
abortion in ohio after the supreme court
ruled last week that it was overturning
roe v wade demonstrating the tangible
impacts that the high court's decision
is having on patients seeking access to
the medical procedure
a chi this is a horrible horrible story
a child abuse doctor in ohio contacted
dr caitlin bernard an obstetrician
gynecologist in indiana after receiving
a 10 year old patient six weeks and
three days pregnant
the patient is now heading west to
indiana given that an abortion ban in
ohio which prohibits the medical
procedure when fetal cardiac activity
begins around six weeks had become
effective quickly after the high court
issued its decision
several groups filed a lawsuit seeking
to block the state law from taking
effect on wednesday an emergency stay of
the abortion ban was rejected by the
ohio supreme court friday meaning the
ban can be upheld as the case is
reviewed
ohio is among a number of states that
have rolled back abortion access since
the supreme court eliminated the
constitutional right to an abortion some
laws have been paused pending legal
challenges but indiana could soon find
itself passing its own abortion law
later this month given that a special
session has been scheduled for later in
july so understand what is going on here
we have had
all sorts of different laws around the
country
over the last
50 years quite frankly the roe v wade
era and in fact longer there are
leftover laws from before the roe v wade
era that were effectively
uh
what's the castrated i don't know the
right word they were sort of like
kneecapped for lack of a better term
because of roe v wade so they're
pre-existing laws that just weren't
really in force because of roe v wade
you then had other laws passed during
the um
uh
roe v wade era
some of which were sort of like inactive
because of roe v wade others which were
actually struck down
um and then
you had some states that have what are
called trigger laws where they say
if roe v wade is suspended or overturned
then this law
goes into effect and some of them
happened immediately and in some places
they are being temporarily stopped
during the review of the law and in some
places they are in place so here is a
non-hypothetical and the reaction from
some is well we should be more concerned
with how the 10 year old got pregnant in
the first place not about giving people
abortion on demand well but hold on a
second
she is pregnant right now
and in fact any delay
for her
reduces the number of places where she
can legally get an abortion right if you
can get if if the idea is well it's too
late in ohio but you can go to indiana
i don't know the law in indiana off the
top of my head but imagine that in
indiana you can go until nine weeks well
if you can delay her two and a half
weeks now she can't get the abortion in
indiana while we figure out how did she
get pregnant in the first place
you need to be concerned both
about how this
happened and how to deal with the
aftermath and forcing a pregnancy on a
10 year old is not going to help her
trauma now is this what what republicans
want is this the country that
republicans want well no they would say
we would prevent the rape pregnancy to
begin with that was one from texas in
texas when texas passed its law
at this point it was a few months ago
maybe a year ago i'm not sure and greg
abbott was asked well what about be
people victims of rape who end up
pregnant or
children victims of rape what and he
said well we're this is texas we're
going to prevent rape
right well even a very well-functioning
uh criminal justice system
is not particularly good at preventing
crime criminal justice systems okay you
look at large-scale frauds of different
kinds and extortions sometimes you you
can prevent crime
but when it comes to street crime and
when it comes to rape and when it comes
to murder and a lot of these different
things law enforcement is not
particularly good at preventing crime we
can we can look at policy that would
reduce the amount of that crime but the
idea
that texas police are going to prevent
these scenarios from ever happening it's
absurd and of course it doesn't work and
doesn't happen
so uh i would say to them well how are
you going to do that here we have a
situation this is exactly what we've
been talking about last week it was a
hypothetical about a 12 year old place
to the mississippi speaker of the house
oh but david that's that's a
hypothetical
well here we've got a real one
and now this 10 year old has to leave
ohio is it better for i mean listen
ultimately she's going to get the
abortion it may already have happened we
it's been a few days you know over the
holiday weekend
is it better for her to have to go to
indiana
and leave ohio because of the law
doesn't seem like it doesn't seem like
it and by the way
there are republicans asked about this
who aren't even saying no no no it would
be totally different in our state let's
talk about that next
so um
south dakota trumpian republican
governor christie gnome
was on cnn over the weekend
and she was asked
hey you know we have this situation in
ohio not that far from south dakota
where a ten-year-old girl is now
pregnant
and she can't get an abortion in ohio
because of the ohio uh anti-abortion
bill so she has to go to indiana and
dana bash from cnn asks christinome
what is going to happen in south dakota
if this ten-year-old were in south
dakota would she be forced to carry the
baby to term now of course implicit in
the question is
or
procuring some kind of unsafe so-called
back alley abortion
uh and i don't even really like the term
back alley because it sort of like puts
shame to it but i think what we mean is
like a a non-medically supervised
abortion of some kind or is she gonna
have to leave south dakota if this
happened because that's really what it
is
and christy gnome
essentially says yeah that's what would
happen check this out let me ask you
about that the indianapolis star is
reporting that a 10 year old girl in
ohio who is six weeks and three days
pregnant now has to travel across state
lines to indiana to receive an abortion
so i just because this is a trigger law
that was passed before you became
governor i wanted you to be clear
will the state of south dakota going
forward force a ten-year-old in that
very same situation to have a
baby i think it's incredible dana in
this tragic story because i heard about
this last night
what's incredible is that nobody's
talking about the
pervert
horrible and deranged individual that
raped a ten-year-old well but oh whoa
that's exactly what i just said of
course we want to talk about that
but the girl is now pregnant and this is
a delay tactic let's spend three weeks
talking about the perverted individual
who did this
so that it becomes even more difficult
for the 10 year old to terminate this
pregnancy this this is what they do i
just said this is exactly what they plan
to do by the way remember the question
is
if this was in your state governor gnome
would this girl be forced to birth this
baby and so far we haven't gotten a no
that means that the answer is yes and
what is it what are we doing about that
i agree what are we doing about i mean
of course that's that's that is an
important discussion to have you're
right
that's an issue that the supreme court
has weighed into this listen
to talk about what we can do for that
little girl i think we also need to be
addressing those sick individuals that
do this to our children i couldn't agree
more but our bodies are our bodies and
women are the ones who
who get pregnant and in this case it
wasn't a woman it was a girl right
should i have to have a child a child
should she have an every single life
every single life is precious that this
tragedy is horrific i can't even imagine
i've never
had anybody in my family or myself gone
through anything like this i can't even
imagine but guys she's saying the
ten-year-old in south dakota would be
forced forced to carry the baby to term
that's what she's saying
in south dakota the law today is that
the abortions are illegal except to save
the life of you you would be okay with
that a ten-year-old girl having to have
a baby no i'm never okay with that in
fact that story will keep me up at night
it absolutely so would you try she'll
stay up thinking about it she's not okay
with it but it's what the law
is to have an exception
in a situation like that
got a one-year-old little granddaughter
named miss addy i can't even imagine
what i would say is i don't believe a
tragic situation should be perpetuated
by another tragedy and so there's more
that we've got to do to make sure that
we really are living a life that says
every life is precious especially
innocent lives
guys she's saying that the answer is yes
understand that she's saying yes
in south dakota
abortions are illegal except to save the
life of the mother if the life of the
mother who in this case is a 10 year old
girl is not endangered by the pregnancy
she should not and would not be allowed
to get an abortion that's that's what
she's saying this is the country
under republicans like christine
there is no other way
to explain it
there is no other way to
sort of uh mitigate what they are saying
yes
in south dakota and in every state if
christinome got her way if whoever get
their way
ten-year-old girls
would be forced to carry pregnancy to
terms think about that
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's do some media
news over the fourth of july weekend
there was such major media news it has
shaken the media world to its very core
jordan peterson who has previously said
he's not political and he's certainly
not right wing is joining the new
right-wing online network the daily wire
the daily wire is apparently now
launching their
i i would it's weird it's not even
really like it's all streaming it's all
online anyway they're launching
something called daily wire plus and i
don't know if plus means it's better or
it's sort of like the dregs that nobody
wants but anyway it's daily wire plus
jordan peterson is going to have a
program on the daily wire plus
the the trailer for this program
looks like it would be a parody of what
you would expect to see from someone
like jordan peterson i watched this
thing twice and i rarely am even
remotely entertained by this stuff
but
this is just wacky the program is called
dragons monsters and men now for those
of you thinking maybe i can find it on
youtube or maybe i can find it on roku
or tick tocks or fire sticks or anything
it will only be on daily wire plus i
don't want you guys to get your hopes up
and think you're just going to be able
to go anywhere and find jordan
peterson's dragons monsters and men
here is
i mean a parody of himself at this point
jordan peterson's new program one of the
things i tell young men on young women
as well but the young men really need to
hear this more i think you should be a
monster
absolute monster and then you should
learn how to control it
so a man who's capable of aggression but
has it under control is a way more
useful man than
one who cannot do that and so you're
willing to go get a job but you're
terrified of an interview it's like
there's a dragon for you because you
want to fight the dragons that guard the
gates of the treasure that you wish to
attain i hope you guys are particularly
the men the women too like he says but
particularly the men i hope you guys are
taking notes um why at this point i mean
listen uh you can be
you can be a good therapist but have
personally a life
that is not going so well
interpersonally you could be
a good
nutritionist but personally
like crap i don't you i think you guys
get the analogy but at this point
peterson's entire life is a shambles
that seems so
uh um
sort of like
uh
unhinged and outrageous in every way
that i don't know why people would still
be saying this is the picture of
stability and the p i just don't get it
i really don't get it at this point it
doesn't make any sense to me
productivity
requires aim orientation responsibility
discipline that willingness to work that
willingness to make sacrifices which is
the hallmark of maturity in the service
of a higher goal even the way they have
them sitting in the chair if you're
watching every down to the last note
every element of this is bizarre
it orients you solidly in the world if
you do that and it gives you a dragon to
fight
right
what do you want to grow up you want to
be illiterate
you want to be inarticulate
you're going to have to negotiate
you're going to have to lead you're
going to have to convince you're gonna
have to think to say to a 18 year old
you're okay the way you are
that just deflates them
you know when you go to the gym and you
start lifting weights well your body's
going to transform but it's not going to
do that if you just sit around you have
to face your being with the necessity of
transformation and then all sorts of
news it's almost like the the i think
what at this point has become kind of
weird about all of this is
it's gone beyond eve it's now just
approximating in the blurriest sense
possible
what is actually actionable advice like
early on there was the first layer of
the jordan peterson stuff where it was
like okay he's sort of giving specific
advice like self-help type stuff
and it's completely
uh unremarkable in that it's a lot of
the same stuff that a lot of people have
been repeating for a long time and so to
the extent that it's useful to hear it
from anybody it might be useful
he now just even dances around it in
such generalities that it's almost like
a horoscope it's the horoscope version
there's been these tests done with
horoscopes where you get people of
different astrological signs i don't
know are there 10 or 12 of them and you
give them all the same horoscope and
they all start to believe if you tell
them that it's the horoscope for their
sign that it applies to them perfectly
even though it's just random it has no
meaning whatsoever
it's sort of a similar thing where it's
just like it's the most generic possible
advice and it's so generic that people
just hear and they go yeah that sounds
reasonable but there's not actually
anything to really act on it's a very
it's almost become a grift of sorts at
this point things that you had no idea
you were capable of will make themselves
manifest those are the dragons you know
the ones that stand in the path that
leads to the light
and you have to say to yourself
i will
do good
nonetheless
everyone great makes that decision
make that decision because maybe you're
great
the only thing missing would be jordan
peterson uh weeping now to announce this
incredible partnership ben shapiro
interviewed i guess jordan peterson and
ben shapiro asked one question
and then uh peterson just droned on and
on and on i've never seen anything like
that i've had interview guests where
it's like close to this but it's never
been this bad jordan obviously this new
series dragons monsters men the first
one that we're doing together this
series is focused in on how men can be
men why do you think there is such a
crisis of masculinity in the first place
and why are there so many people out
there who are angry at you for even
talking to men
well i think it's i think you could
think about it as a consequence in some
sense of the lack of a concept of
original sin
right now i just dipped into it at
random like i just clicked around and
peterson's just droning at every
instance compassion that has this
devouring quality and
yeah and that's basically where we're at
so
so
i found the other question shapiro was
able to ask
no it's
one of the things that's striking about
the sort of hatred that you've gotten
from so many is that you you've
literally been asked why you're even
bothering to speak to men i mean there
is this question of masculinity right
there is this idea that so he basically
asks the same question again and then
peterson's just going and go
power i'll define that as the
willingness and ability to use
compulsion
to attain your aims now if you are
someone who
has a proclivity to manifest
power right okay here's another one
power is the fundamental
motivation and that's and then you think
too
okay you're only motivated by power that
means that we can only get along if our
interests align because if you're
motivated okay and then just one other
moment this is the manifestation of the
spirit of voluntary play and that's so
lovely because there's nothing all right
i'm not going to subject you guys to
more of it but that is the new
partnership jordan peterson who's not
political and not a right winger
partnering up with the hard right media
conglomerate the daily wire i'm sure it
will be a fascinating show if any of you
watch it please let me know how
did you survive
okay i think we are getting very close
to being able to sort of close the door
proverbially and maybe at some point a
literal door
on my pillow ceo and founder mike
lindell
he actually quote testified before the
louisiana senate committee
looking at
i guess voter fraud it's the voting
system commission they were exploring
voter fraud
and he
very quickly imploded and tried to cite
some kind of weird data that he has
access to which proves based on an
investigation of votes that he did
that it's all fraudulent and trump won
or whatever and the thing you have to
remember is
does he even have ac aside from does the
data or do the data show what he claims
does pillow even have access to such
data and it's not a question we actually
have an answer to but here's a little
bit of his testimony for lack of a
better term last thing i'll say is our
overseas votes this is where they were
going to and when you say computers you
want to know the next era emailing and
and uh texting in your vote right now
you say that could never happen right
all of our military was almost 97 were
emailed in from overseas and their
families
all of them that we found so far were
for biden
and that's our overseas military class
so that's a pretty big claim we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah okay so what does he mean
by
investigated votes since he doesn't
really have access to that information
but this is not a new claim the the
claim that he's making is
we've investigated overseas votes
and they were all for biden which
doesn't make sense it just doesn't that
you would expect to see some trump votes
this has been claimed before
the claim is specific to georgia and
it's if you look at georgia military
overseas ballots
they were all for biden and thus it's
evidence of voter fraud this was widely
investigated early in 2021
this conspiracy theory website called
the gateway pundit made a similar claim
saying quote in georgia
a sample now this is a key word a sample
of military ballots were reviewed
recently and all went for joe biden
there's no way these were legit so the
first question is is it true that all
the overseas military ballots in georgia
were for biden and the answer is no
notice that the gateway pundit uses this
phrase a sample of overseas ballots
this was investigated and what they
found is that there are some batches of
votes
that were all biden votes so for example
there was a batch of 130 ballots
those were all biden and there's a
reason for that they had already been
sorted by candidate so think about the
way that this worked the ballots come in
massive dumps of ballots as all of you
guys know about
you go okay
we're gonna put the biden ballots in one
box
and we're gonna put the trump ballots in
another box so you sort them and you've
got a box of all biden ballots you hand
that box to someone to review and they
go hey every single one of these is for
biden it must be fraud as they like to
say well no it's just they were
correctly sorted and you're looking at a
biden box of ballots so it makes sense
that if they were correctly sorted that
they would all be biden the georgia
secretary of state's office
did a hand recount of those they were
able to quote uphold and reaffirm the
original outcome there were two other
audits done of georgia's results
including looking at 15 000 absentee
ballots there was no evidence of
widespread fraud if i do an initial sort
and it's correct and then you review the
sort you would anticipate that you would
have a large tranche of trump boxes
and a large tranche of biden boxes
that's all that happened here and the
claims are now starting to be at
starting
they've always been absurd but the
claims are now so transparently
toothless there's nothing there
that my expectation is in the next four
months particularly as we get closer to
the midterms that the pillow stuff is
going to wind down once you're beyond
the midterms and even the people who
believe this stuff are starting to think
you know mike
it might not all be just about to come
out in a blockbuster way
i think you'll see a dramatic reduction
in the amount we hear from pillow i
could be wrong but at least that's me
optimistically thinking we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p in the aftermath of another
horrible holiday weekend of more mass
shootings in the united states radical
repugnant ridiculous republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
is taking out an old
toy from the bag of toys i guess
antidepressants are to blame for the
mass shootings
uh a voicemail um about that take a
listen
hey david so uh marjorie taylor greens
tweet about
antidepressants now for certain
antidepressants
being the problem
i mean you know obviously since she's a
doctor she knows best but there's a real
good way they're complaining about
mental illness real good way to handle
let's take a bunch of
people off their meds and see how they
cope and see what happens i'm sure
all the problems will be magically
solved no more shooting having stuff
unbelievable this woman should be
medicated seriously somebody
somebody needs to diagnose a
professional help
okay yes so starting to meander a bit
but the the caller correctly assesses
marjorie taylor green has again linked
uh and by again i mean others have done
it i don't know if this is the first
time she's done it or not she's linking
antidepressants to mass shootings
and unfortunately this is one of those
things where it starts to be repeated
uncritically
and people just seem to lose their
ability to think
and one of the things that
if you really want to study whether
antidepressants cause people to commit
mass shootings
you would probably be able to set up
such an experiment and i'd have to think
about the best way to do it it's not
been done and unfortunately you can't
really just say hey if some shooters
have been on antidepressants we have to
blame the antidepressants in fact it
could be that those already
identified as struggling in certain ways
or diagnosed for certain conditions
which might predispose them to violence
are then put on antidepressants and the
antidepressants are
a correlation and not at all a causation
it would sort of be like saying hey you
know we're noticing
i'm making this up okay but imagine that
we said i'm noticing that
the people who have heart attacks
are often on blood thinners at a higher
rate than the general population maybe
the blood thinners cause the heart
attacks then you have to step back and
say well hold on a second if the blood
thinners are being prescribed to a group
at higher risk of heart attack we have
to consider
whether it is a correlation that is not
a causation that there is a sort of
confounding factor and in fact without
the blood thinners maybe that group
would have an even higher rate of heart
attack i'm making that up i don't know
if that phenomenon exists
but it's an important one to think about
when we talk about the antidepressant
thing if antidepressants cause mass
shootings would we want to know that of
course we would why wouldn't we want to
know that there is no such evidence at
this time and alex this is alex jones
level stuff alex jones has talked about
that uh others have talked about it
again as part of this concerted effort
to talk about everything
other than guns when it comes to mass
shootings we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today producer pat is back
from hawaii he will tell us did he see
tulsi gabbard while there
and also what was he up to
i am very curious to hear about it i've
never been
to the 50th state of the united states
but i would love to go we're going to
hear from pat we will also talk about a
growing problem in the united states
that in many other parts of the world is
not really a problem the lack of public
restrooms
including in our very own new york city
okay we will talk about all of that and
more on the bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad well easy there sign up at
joinpakman.com
you'll get access to the bonus show you
can use the coupon code big voting22 to
get a discount
and we will see you then or tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below